I suppose in my own field of biology it
would be molecular genetics it has
enormous potential its advancing as an
extremely rapid rate
coupled with computer science which is
also advancing at an extremely rapid
rate and the two are genuinely coupled
that's no accident Moore's law in the
world of computer science states that
computer power measured in various ways
increases exponentially and it's
doubling time is something like 18
months there's another law which I've
coined Hodgkin law which says that
sequencing genomes the power to read
genomes increases exponentially and the
doubling time is not quite as fast as
that it's such it's more like 27 months
but Hodgkin law and Moore's law are
related because genetic sequencing is
the technology is very dependent upon
computers and so part of what in what
has fed into the increase in the rate of
the increase in in the part of sequence
genomes has been the increase in
computer power which is which is Moore's
law so the two together are rendering
our world ever stranger ever faster and
the internet as we now know it would
would have totally astounded me if when
I first had first started using
computers in the 1960s I dimly thought
that something like mean this from
internet mass communication might come
about but I never thought it would be
anything like as powerful as it is I
would have been just blown over
backwards if somebody had suddenly
plunked me in front of a modern but put
pushed me forward in time to to 2009 and
showed me a modern computer and a modern
internet connection that the same thing
is happening and is going to happen to
biology with respect to genome
sequencing and it's going to become
possible to sequence the genome of an
individual of any species for very
little money very fast
and that's going to open up enormous
vistas for biological research and for
medicine because it means that for
example doctors instead of prescribing a
sort of generic treatment for the
disease you've got for an average person
will prescribe this particular treatment
that you in as an individual need
because of the particular fingerprint of
genes that you've got that's that that's
going to be a radical change in medicine
but in biological research it means that
we can just sequence the genome of any
species we like very quickly biologists
of the future may be able to catch an
animal or plant in in the wild stick a
probe into it and immediately read out
of a sort of iPhone dial its genome this
would be a an astonishing leap in
research power
well it's becoming
being closer all the time it's all it's
already possible to sequence a genome
for a few I forget how I forget what it
is but I mean it's a manageable number
of dollars it still is still a lot but
in bye-bye um 2050 it would be possible
to sequence the genome of an individual
for probably tens of dollars and that
would be quite extraordinary state of
affairs